see how things are moving along on the
commute let's go to the boat i Nate home
studios alright Jerry so the most of the
freeways here in town are doing great we
are anticipating that there'll be more
folks coming into town for the holiday
weekend by car certainly McCarran
Airport is seeing an increase in travel
as well but mainly it's going to be on
the roadways
now our traffic maps showing that the
roads in town are doing okay there might
be some slowing westbound on the far
northern to 15 Beltway say from about
Pecos overpass 5th Street over towards
Aliante Parkway but we did want to alert
you to a crash and particularly for the
folks who are heading into the Las Vegas
area from the south north not on the
i-15 this crash is around Sloan that's
the little exit there were speed Vegas
before you get st. Rose Parkway before
we get to the live camera I want to let
you know that the traffic map is still
showing green there so everybody's
moving along headlights those are the
southbounders heading for the California
border there you see the crash off on
the right what little traffic there is
is moving right along there is a crash
in the far southwest we'll talk about
that in our next report John